or to other news and a heat wave is
moving across southeast Asia pushing
temperatures to record levels in India
at least 11 people died of heat stroke
this week schools and colleges and some
provinces have been closed well
Bangladesh is seeing its highest
temperatures in almost 60 years and
seasonal rains have so far failed to
appear regions across China are
reporting record April highs and many
wildfires with the hottest months of the
year still to come in Thailand the
Mercury surpassed 45 degrees Celsius for
the first time ever on Friday climate
experts there warn the extreme heat and
drought May last for months we're going
to go to tanvi choudhary who is coming
to us from the Bangladesh capital of
Dhaka and is there any respite at all
there at this point in time tamfir
well the no respite really there's no
rain the monsoon season officially
started in the middle of this month
April and there's no sight of rain
except for a little bit of rain in the
northeast of the country other than that
it's been dry heat wave all across the
country for the last two weeks
temperature raising as you just
mentioned over 40 degrees in some parts
of the country the capital city itself
experienced 41.1 on last Sunday which
was one of the highest since almost 60
years now this is the month of Ramadan
in a Muslim majority country most people
are fasting from dust to done and it's
become very challenging particularly for
the working people those working as Rick
shuffler day laborers and in the
industries also people living in the
slum with tin Roots a lot of internal
migration due to the impact of climate
people from coastal areas migrate to the
urban areas that's a major challenge in
the urban city like Dhaka which has
grown grown since 1980s used to be 17
percent greeneries now it has barely two
percent greeneries in the city a lot of
it is man-made intervention a lot of the
canals and the wetlands are grabbed by
land Grabbers Four Rivers surrounding
the city are narrowed they're also
grabbed by land Grabbers making the
climate much more eventful because of
this and heavy traffic concrete building
and take radiate hits making it
extremely difficult now because of the
monsoon people who'd normally get
respite during this time but we haven't
seen that the farmers are worried
because there's no rain they could
threaten their agriculture production
the government say that by
2040 the total working hours could be
lost as much as five percent cutting
into 4.9 percent of the GDP so it does
recognize the heat stress is a major
challenge particularly in the urban
areas almost majority of the People by
2050 would be living in cities across in
Bangladesh so the climate change does
have a name back we have seen that in
recent years heavy Cyclones and frequent
flood in the country so much challenge
ahead for the country to deal with
climate impacts okay thank you so much
tembia that's 10 very challengry for us
in the Bangladesh Capital Dhaka
well for more on the Azure Heat Wave
let's bring in Al Jazeera meteorologist
Rob McAuley now Rob is the worst over or
things just heating up I think you've
got an idea from tanvir it's going to
get worse in some places but uh it's a
big place I mean we expected the pre-man
student heat in in India anyway in fact
India and Pakistan will see temperatures
rise but not as fiercely this year as
they did last year Bangladesh was the
surprise in that it hit 40 degrees for
the first time in about 58 years 40.6 in
fact and you don't expect any relief
from the rain just yet but wait till May
we'll have a look at that in just a
second but the real heat actually has
been around for a bit longer and a bit
further east in for example attack in
Thailand either Friday on Saturday I
think it's probably been uh Saturday
45.4 first time I've ever been recorded
in the country and it's not just
Thailand it's true in Myanmar as well
it's also been reported this morning as
of yesterday that Laos has reported its
highest ever temperature
42.7 at all time National records so
this part of Asia has been extremely hot
and that spread across into China now
last year China had virtually no
significant rate as a drought problem
however that drought problem may be
relieved in places but given that the
you see the cloud is to the East and
this is flooding as a result in fujian
that rain is not falling where the heat
has been which has basically been around
Yunnan we've seen big fires as a result
of that but the rain has started and if
I bring you back to finish off now
towards Bangladesh the forecast is to
see a few more showers build in the sky
and I have to say Tom in May you get
huge thunderstorms in Bangladesh so it
will be cooler but they're dangerous
thunderstorms of course thank you so
much thanks Rob
well